I'm having kind of a hard time when I have all these x's floating around. So,
let's just take it easy. Let's write a super simple inequality, maybe 1 is less
than 2. Those are two numbers that I think I can handle right now. Let's check
this on a number line to make sure that I'm not crazy. Well here's 1 and here's
2. We're going to look at just the range of values that is less than 2, and that
is all of these values to the left of 2. 1 is definitely in this interval. But,
I was looking at our earlier inequality, I ran into a problem when I divided
both sides of the inequality by negative 1. I'll make some room here, and now,
let's see what happens if I divide both sides of the inequality by negative 1.
So, what number do we get on either side of our inequality, if we divide both
sides by negative 1? Make sure you keep the numbers on the sides that they're on
right now for the purposes of this answer. After that, I would like you to
consider your answer, and tell me whether or not this makes sense.